darren beatty has thought a lot about
what elon musk should do to save this
nation's public discourse he edits
revolver.news and we're happy to have
him join us tonight daryn thanks so much
for coming on what do you think elon
musk will do what should he do
well first of all i think
he needs to understand exactly what he's
getting into
he's stepping into the war zone
in a way that he might not even be able
to imagine at this point as you point
out the entire regime depends on
holding a total monopoly over what elon
rightly calls the global public square
anyone who threatens that steps into
territory that is not a normal financial
realm twitter is not a normal company
the question of who controls twitter is
far more consequential than say
who controls home depot even though home
depot is vastly larger as a company and
so elon needs to be prepared for what's
coming it would be one of the few things
that is not fake and not performative it
would amount to effectively
a declaration of war
on our corrupt and illegitimate regime
he must understand that i mean i don't
know elon musk but he he sees a lot of
things coming that the rest of us don't
so he must know what he's playing with
here
well um i would hope so but i think it's
very
it's very easy to underestimate the
stakes here the stakes of who controls
the global public square
are vastly more than the meager 30
billion dollars that twitter is
allegedly worth
the stakes of who controls the global
public square
is more important even than an electric
car company and in fact i would say
winning the political battle in the west
is more is just as relevant to the
future of human civilization than even
space travel
because after all we're bringing our
memes to space
well i agree with that completely so why
wouldn't just to sum up why why not
democratize it why wouldn't musk say to
the american public if you're on board
join me in buying shares of this
publicly traded company
pledge me your proxy votes and let's
take it over and restore free speech
i think that's a splendid idea
i imagine there are a variety of
mechanisms but it all catches out to
this a declaration of war on the regime
and i really hope that elon will go
ahead with it that he's not just another
rich guy that he's someone who wants to
be a great man and this is one of the
few real steps that he can make and he's
one of the very few live players on this
earth who's in a position to do it
i don't think you're overstating the
stakes at all darren beatty thank you
for joining us thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight